so how you guys do this is the middle of
your day beginning of the day ya know we
got the premiere tonight we got the hope
I'm in I'm gonna give an after-party yes
old congratulations on this on this
gorgeous fill in this gorgeous story
it's just such an important film I think
and I think I just love that this this
film is out there for people that might
need it thank you yeah so I'm wondering
if you Joe remember the the moment you
realize that this was going to be the
story that was gonna get you back behind
the camera I I knew that I wanted to be
involved when I got deep into the memoir
it literally was the moment where
Jared's mother and here kind of getting
out breaking out in a way and and the
reason I felt that is because I didn't
know whether it be worth making a movie
that was just about a torture facility
with no hope why I thought it was worth
putting on the screen is because you
know I'm fascinated with humans making
mistakes and being willing to re-examine
those choices and and the fact that
guards mother had such a turnaround at a
similar moment as he was discovering his
own agency I was like there's two pieces
of hope here is that young people know
how to forge their own paths despite the
obstacles and that growing up people you
can teach an old dog new tricks and I
thought there's a hopefulness in that
and it's worth telling his story for you
I have to assume that that writing the
memoir in the first place might have
been like reliving these experiences we
lived in this life Oliver yeah I'm
wondering if seeing this movie get made
and then seeing the finished product
sort of felt like reliving that for a
second time yeah the first time it was
incredibly difficult to reconstruct the
type of mindset that I had during that
time because I'm so you know far left of
where it was back then but it was
incredibly important to get it right and
so when Joel what really wanted to get
the movie right in terms of tone I was
thrilled about that but I wasn't
expecting to watch from the outside my
own story because it felt like I hadn't
Lee had more compassion for myself
because I could see that especially with
Lucas's wonderful performance you can
see how he didn't do anything wrong
you know he had almost no choice but to
say yes to go to conversion therapy and
so it's a bit cathartic to do that and
to not have the the safety in some ways
of my voice carrying us along and then
yeah it's just been it's a strange thing
to watch it I put it but it is cathartic
tightly tightly I thought yeah that
someone said to me they're gonna tend my
life get film I'll be like I already
live yeah yeah do I get an audition yeah
Russell Crowe can you're my dad
yeah that's it so it's interesting to me
that this movie seems to have empathy
for for everyone it's not just it's not
just for Jeff it's for its for anyone
that comes across the screen the movie
sort of he does a little bit into why
they are the way they are and I'm
wondering why that was important to come
across for you well I felt I was shocked
there was one of the most startling
things about the book was that it's
dedicated to his parents and my great
fear as a child was being sent away from
my parents to an institution it was one
of the races I read the book so quick I
never ever imagined that the people
would that would send me away from my
parents would be my parents and and that
double fear kind of startled me but but
garrard then rendered them in the memoir
is in real life he understood why that
the choices to send him to conversion
therapy and the reason conversion
therapy exists I perceived preconceived
that it would be a hateful practice
created by hateful people you know
painful by hateful other people sending
their kids well it was paid for by hate
for people
yeah out of love and a feeling like that
were able to help you yeah I thought
that's so complicated and I would never
seen that the detail and fibre of that
decision is being like a decision that
they thought was positive yeah I mean in
our crosshairs was never like the
parents or necessarily the lower
churches that were involved I think the
higher up the power goes that's why I
see a night like yeah
funded by - because we know we know who
funded a lot
yeah yeah let's say you know the higher
up you go that's that's how you attack
and I don't think I think you try to
understand and hold accountable the
parents I mean in no way do you not hold
these these two characters accountable
from what they did oh yeah Nicole you
know it's variable growth but I'm not
creating a myth as to what as to that it
coming from a mustache twirling a damn
place that's too easy
it's a very interesting evolution that I
saw within this true story of a
particularly of a mother who did
something she thought she was doing out
of love she created rather than help she
recognized the hurt and the pain and was
willing to re-examine that choice and
that to me was a hopeful enough place of
a foundation to creatives
a roadmap to other people if they mess
up when here's how you get out of this
situation
mm-hmm there are several scenes where in
this film where the camera is just as a
static it's not it's holding on
something that's uncomfortable to watch
but it doesn't you know doesn't cut away
doesn't shy away and I'm wondering why
that was important in the making of this
film to keep the camera just right on
the horrific act that's taking place
well I just have this instinct like if
you are undergoing something that is
horrific there's no escape that that in
order for the audience to feel at least
a distance observational portion of that
discomfort that you have to put them in
that place as well in the only reason I
think the scene you're talking about you
know it's probably the most hard to what
scene in the film inclusive and it is
the only reason there's editing is
because I felt the need to make it even
more brutal and it and make it longer
but yeah the need to hold on things that
are uncomfortable I think audiences are
able to deal with that knowing that
they're at a distance you know that's
all just instinct stuff as a filmmaker
and I love I love watching movies that I
flinch and you know I did that my memoir
- I stayed in the moment for long
periods of time I think that's yeah we
were sort of communicating that way -
anything so much of Lucas's performances
is an internal one it's easy it's a very
quiet performance it's very
just withdrawn performance on purpose I
assume and I'm wondering how you how you
draw out the emotions you need the
audience to understand when so much of
it is happening beneath the surface it's
a real challenge because you know the
this guy has pointed out the the memoirs
very internal you know in a memoir could
be very internal I I it was a real
challenge for me and a learning
experience even throughout shooting and
then cutting the film about how to at
least get inside those thoughts to a
degree and and particularly his
relationship with belief willingness to
undergo therapy devotion to it and the
beginning of questioning that was going
to snowball into his agency and then
allowing that silence and and
compression of his being put upon to be
not a lovely explosion of self power and
and and outward kind of agency you know
and it was a challenge calibrating that
central characters that are kind of you
know put upon and and preached to and
talked to a lot it's tricky but that's
the beautiful thing about Lucas is an
actor you can hold that space
you